do you think you're going to be ready to
get rid of Hedonism and hoes and stuff
like that that's the conversations I
have with religious people a lot I was
talking about young dominant that he's a
Christian I'm like how do you give up on
drinking and girls and all the Hinduism
and like when you decide that's done
because I feel like I would be more
boring you know it doesn't like and to
the people that didn't see our stream
with young Don please please just watch
him bro it's crazy but I'm still gonna
say male like
I mean like indulging in that in the
Hedonism make you more exciting and
entertaining and be able to like all the
[ __ ] that you do with milk boys like the
happy Dad and full send that's all like
it's not anti-islam but it's a lot of it
is Haram like drinking all the time and
I I talk about religion all the time too
but I
I drink partake in all that nonsense
when do you think you're gonna be ready
to give up on that uh I think honestly
speaking in the next couple years when
something like around 25 26. bro like
because this is this shit's just not a
game bro like it's just like I can't
personally get to a religion like this
in my own if I'm not going to be
completely honest with myself man I'm
not gonna like just be like you know
what I'm saying like I'm never gonna
like
bro I'm not just gonna call myself a
Muslim but I'm not bro like that's just
how it works but drinking was bro
huh why do you say five years from now
uh because I think right now is
you know I mean it kind of sounds cliche
in a way it's not ready I don't think
I'm ready now because obviously you know
maybe it's selfish upon my point upon
myself with you know wanting to you know
explore life and that goes back to what
you're saying about the whole
having making your life interesting and
stuff like that right but like
I mean maybe I'm wrong with having that
type of decision you know maybe I'm
wrong with saying yo maybe in a couple
years let me just have my fun you know
what I mean let me just have my fun and
get into religion but I don't think you
know it is wrong I'm not gonna lie it is
wrong you think you need to get it out
of your system before you fall and
that's and I I don't personally know if
that's
you know the right thing to do yeah and
neither do I because I think bro
the Bro the practice was the practice of
Islam bro it's like
bro it's just it's so much how do I
explain it it's like
just the discipline and
it's like it's like teaching a kid not
the bad things in the world when they're
obviously like you know they're born bro
I didn't know any of this like could you
imagine like I like look back on that
until I was 17.
and then obviously when I moved out and
everything like that like had my own
thing but I didn't know any of this
could you imagine doing that for the
next 40 years 50 years I mean I'm sure a
lot of these guys I practice Islam and
stuff right they don't need some even
know this life why why even know this
like and you know one of those something
that's special about it there's really
not but obviously you wanna you know
when you have those nights where you're
like man we're getting [ __ ] hammered
all this [ __ ] you know everything's
going great it's just like bro like I
feel like a lot of people don't uh
understand the the important importance
of like Simplicity in life too which is
something I had and my parents had
that's why it's kind of giving me chills
just watching this [ __ ] it's crazy like
this guy it's so like weird listening to
this right now Celine mentioned that he
wanted to wait five six years to leave
25 26 whatever to start practicing but
like how do you know you're gonna live
that long what if you live you know four
and a half years or four four point nine
years and then you die
like I mean it's it's a serious question
go like go to the graveyard and find
somebody your age or who's 25 or 26 who
who died
what if you're like you know what
maybe in a year I'll give all this stuff
up and you die before then then what how
are you gonna return to Allah and you're
going to return and say what what are
you going to say oh I was planning on
doing it in a year it's like
seriously you think a religion you know
that Allah has given you the blessing of
Life Allah has given you you could just
toy with it screw off for five to six
years do everything you know is Haram
even if you don't call yourself Muslim
you know what's Haram and you know it's
forbidden by Allah and you still do it
and this is not at him specifically this
is not anyone and it's just I want you
to really think about it what if you
don't live that long and also I
mentioned this in the Andrew Tate one of
the entertain reaction videos
one of the 50. you can go you know spend
two years trying to find this quote from
me but snickle talked about Hedonism
Hedonism for those who don't know is the
word that's been passed you know around
a lot recently Hedonism is the pursuit
of you know one's physical pleasure the
pursuit of indulging in physical
pleasure
and they do this because they think it
makes them happy you know and it sounds
sounds silly but people do it because
they it makes them feel good makes them
feel happy
but if you if you think about it if you
think about it what does it mean to
pursue something fayad if I'm pursuing
something do I have it or do I not have
it
Hedonism specifically is the pursuit of
instant gratification not just physical
pleasure yeah yeah so it's people that
are just putting the now over anything
else oftentimes majority of times Ram is
right most of the hedonistic things we
do are physical drugs
in you know fornication all the things
the youth are caught up into you know
but it's just instant you just you just
want what's now you don't think about
consequences you don't think of outcomes
you don't think of a delayed nothing
like that yeah if you're pursuing
something do you have it or do you not
have it you don't have it you don't have
it so if you're pursuing happiness what
does that mean
you don't have happiness you don't you
don't have it and what has happened is
happiness is a feeling it is a feeling
so you're bound to feel it and then not
feel it and so on and so forth like that
will happen
and people are looking for the wrong
thing people do these things to try and
feel happy make themselves happy they're
looking for the wrong thing they're
setting themselves up for failure and
the true Rat Race in life living in the
west with Western values is continually
trying to make yourself happy I
genuinely think most people are
depressed because they don't understand
this very basic thing they're depressed
because they believe they deserve more
in life that they don't have they're
depressed because they believe they
should be here their life should be here
they deserve this and they don't have it
so they experience some type of
cognitive dissonance because what they
believe reality should be is not how
reality is and it hurts them I've been
there it's what you experience when
somebody passes away you've spent your
whole life with them all of a sudden
they're not there you know it's like I
should have this thing but I don't it
will hurt so what people should really
be looking for is contentment because
the definition of contentment has
happiness in it
contentment is the state of being happy
happiness is just the feeling
if you have you heard the story of the
fisherman who goes and he catches like
three fish
um and he's he's content with it and he
goes home
so there's basically there's a story I
don't know the origin of it but it's the
message that matters a fisherman goes he
catches like three fish or whatever then
he calls it a day he goes home and
somebody wants him and asked him like
you know you fish for you know freaking
an hour two hours you catch three fish
and leave why don't you catch more he's
like why for what he's like so you can
sell it like okay and then what and then
you can make a lot of money okay and
then what then you can you know buy more
boats and and buy pay for fishermen and
employ them and make more money and get
a busy big business and it's like okay
and then what it's like what's the point
of all that he's like I'm content with
with just this
if a person is content making twenty
thousand dollars a year they're not
suffering obviously they're not
suffering they're making twenty thousand
dollars a year that's enough for them
they're happy with their wife and their
kids
what more do they really need
they only really become sad or depressed
when they look at other people they're
like wow they have you know all of this
stuff and that's why the prophet peace
upon me told us look at those who have
less than you don't look at those who
have more because you're gonna end up
becoming jealous and being ungrateful to
Allah look at those who have lust so you
can be grateful to Allah Hedonism is is
just a one-way ticket to honestly the
Hellfire in a very depressing and sad
life
hmm I'm mean bro and I was dealing with
one of my clients you know P addiction
people suffering with pmo and watching
Haram and then I was dealing with
another one and then I was dealing with
another one this was like months ago and
I came to a point where I realized most
of my clients are going through the same
thing
and it's probably because most men are
going through the same thing
and this brings us to it no I'm just
playing no spots are here but most men
are for real going through this so I
talked to wahab you know the Warner on
YouTube
on something like I was like driving
somewhere and I was like I'm asking a
lot of different you know people in my
circle this question so I'm gonna ask
you this too what is your solution to
quitting this addiction what helps you I
know what helps me Romney knows what
helps him oh no knows what helps him
everyone has their own thing what is
your thing he said
once you come to a point of realizing
and it ties into directly into what you
said bro but it's like the inverse once
you realize
not only is Hedonism a black hole but
this urge that you have as a man right
that you think one last video will make
you go away you think one last drink
might make you go one last joint one
last whatever might make your urge go
away
it never will because you know bro you
know it's going to come back you know
every single time you said I'm just
gonna do it one more time I'm just gonna
get off and then I'm never gonna think
about it again you always end up
thinking about it again so once you come
to terms with accepting that this will
be a fire that you never put out you
will always consciously continuously
feel this urge this addiction this drive
this feeling this impulse then you can
change the question into how do I stop
feeling this to okay I'm always going to
feel this but what can I do about it how
do I manage it how do I control it now
it's no longer how do I not feel it
anymore how do I get it out of my system
you're never going to get out of your
system for a lot of these things but how
do I now deal with it and come to the
terms with it and now move on how do I
control it now how do I hone it it's
literally a war bro with you against
shaytan you against your nose now it's
no longer delusion like oh just one more
time and then one more drink one more
this
100 I think that's very beautifully said
and it really ties into a point that
another thing I've been thinking about a
lot recently which is like let's take
these these practices of Hedonism is
what I'm going to call them let's look
at drinking
generally speaking and I think you're
the one who told me about this people
don't actually like drinking they just
do it because it's a social thing and
it's basically being in the social
Gathering that's fun and doing this this
this action of drinking with them and
getting drunk and being you know
basically an idiot or being a drunk
idiot is it fun waking up the next
morning most of the time it's not is it
fun waking up in a bed with a random
person don't run from last night I'd
imagine not
so drinking is not actually something
that's desirable and if you need to
drink to have fun then that's very very
sad for you if I'm going to be
completely honest okay next let's look
at you know having uh sex with men women
whatever being intimate with people
okay so you're gonna go you're gonna
knock somebody up You're Gonna Knock
booths with somebody whatever and then
and then what
and then what really
eventually you're gonna feel either
nothing and it's gonna be worthless and
useless for you because we've done it so
many times so many different people it's
not worth it anymore or you're gonna
contract some kind of STI or STD or are
you going to get somebody pregnant or
some kind of negative consequence will
eventually present itself
would you rather go around screwing
around random people and and you know
just to feel this this physical pleasure
for you know what freaking five minutes
of your life again and again and again
and again or would you rather and I want
to tie a personal example in here me I
got married recent alhamdulillah I swear
to God and this isn't a way I cannot
describe it the contentment of being
married
is is a whole other like universe
imagine getting married to a good Muslim
man or woman
who is good to you loyal to you fair to
you and gives you your rights
both have the same beliefs without the
same lifestyle you're both happy and
content with each other
people don't want to talk about
especially men
but when sex is not emotional
it's
it's it's I want to say almost useless
to be completely honest it's actually
negative when it's not emotional it's
negative because there's always that
aspect missing and then shame and guilt
comes in the way is useless
so what is Hedonism for what are these
hedonistic practices for you're gonna go
and get drunk okay You're Gonna Knock uh
somebody up okay like what do you
achieve from that can you not have fun
any other way bro go play basketball
go play soccer
like these things are fun even if you're
gonna watch your freaking YouTube video
or you know watch a twitch stream or
something whatever you know it's better
than going and and getting yourself
addicted to these things that will not
benefit you in the slightest
yeah bro because at the end of the day
things that are Haram are harmed for a
reason and they damage your soul they
literally destroy your spirituality and
you're gonna feel that bro in one way
shape or form some time or another
um so to touch on your first of all bro
any of my clients see me drink from this
plastic bottle bro just don't even
comment anything just get out of here
bro yeah no you know what kills you
testosterone bro listen I just got back
from a long holiday and I don't even
know where my water bottle is you know
how it is on vacation bro plastic balls
that's all you got because yes I know
that you bring anything in
um
now
pertaining to your thing about the whole
water thing or the whole drinking thing
they did they did a study it's called
the Princeton drinking study you can
look it up and they actually survey it
was one of the biggest surveys bro they
went to people door-to-door on campus
asking them do you actually like the
drink or do you not like to drink or do
you have any other reason bro majority
I'm talking like the overwhelming like
80 or 90 majority of people hated to
drink they didn't even like to drink but
the only reason they drank was because
they saw everyone else indulging and
drinking and they thought they were
supposed to like it too
subhanallah like they literally
brainwashed themselves into thinking
they should like something even though
they actually don't
look at all these empowered feminists
that think that they're you know they're
putting something forward which
shouldn't be put forward and they're
suppressing femininity that shouldn't be
you know suppressed at all and it's
actually their gift and they don't want
to be moms and all this
look how look how much they've bought
this delusion and they've convinced them
even though deep Bro the amount of women
I'm not gonna mention y'all's names but
the amount of women I've literally asked
the amount of sisters Cut Throat like
I'm talking like I just Stone Cold
Austin
do you actually like that you're a
feminist
and then all of them somehow
pushed back to the statement of you know
what like I actually don't but like I
can't not be because women fall for this
and XYZ and I have to do this and they
just they just buy their own BS bro
and
once you peel some you know layers back
I've even had you know I was talking to
someone in the past and they were like
my inner feminist is
kind of you know cringing that I even
said that
and what they said was
I just want a man to like take charge
and make me feel at ease and not make me
worry about everything and stress about
everything
why is that a bad thing why are you why
are you sad that you said that you know
what I mean so if we stop buying our own
garbage
that we were trying to convince
ourselves is true
we can be honest with ourselves that we
actually don't nobody likes drinking bro
it's it's horrible I've heard it it
tastes horrible I've heard from people
that drink and they're like you just you
just feel like garbage and then you see
all these hangover commercials the next
day you feel like no one likes it bro
same with substance addiction bro
and I know people are going to comment
you know fine normally talking about
this what if what if I'm that one guy
that drinks but I actually don't end up
drunk driving what if I'm that one
person that drinks and I don't end up
doing something stupid well the question
I'll ask you is everyone that that you
know drives drunk is farther down along
that same path that you're on
everyone that killed themselves off of
mental psychosis or whatever doing drugs
or OD or whatever is literally on the
same path that you're on they're just
further down anyone that got addicted to
pee and then they got erectile
dysfunction
they're just farther down the route that
you're on the problem is you're you're
just not as far down that path so you
don't think you'll ever get there but
the road that you're on only leads there
so why don't you you know turn back or
get on a different path because you
might not be as far gone as the but
you're heading in the same direction as
them
absolutely and listen even if you never
drink enough to you know drunk drive or
whatever how do you know you're not
damaging your body how do you know
you're not going to end up with some
kind of like liver disease in the future
or something like that and there's a big
study I forgot who it was a very rich
person I don't want to get the name
wrong but his organization did a huge
study on the last like it was an insane
amount of cancer
um
what's the word I'm looking for
uh cancer cases I'll just say right and
they found that like 99 of them in the
same amount were linked to obesity
alcohol or smoking
if not you know one case will have
multiple instances of those things how
many people do you know that are
overweight morbidly obese the alcoholics
and they smoke bro
it's very sad it's very sad but of
course what is the root of all of this
what is the root of this madness the
root of this madness is liberalism oh no
he's talking our liberal belief yes I am
because it's destroying you when you
believe
that you should basically do what
Pleasures you and avoid what harms you
and whatever such an arbitrary General
useless rule I I want to say honestly at
this point because what if something
that Pleasures you now harms you in the
future and you don't know about it
what is something that harms you now is
actually pleasuring you or will lead to
a better lifestyle in the future and you
don't know about it it's such a stupid
rule because humans are are naturally
biased they're they're they naturally
lack enough information in a lot of
cases to make a good decision especially
in the case of like morality or what
should or shouldn't be done in certain
cases when it comes to you know our
pleasure and our desire and stuff but
who knows Allah knows so listen you want
to have sex that's not a problem get
married do it the right way feel an
emotional proper intimate connection and
Link with your spouse do it the right
way you want to have fun bro go play
basketball or soccer even Call of Duty
or whatever with your friends
do something Halal no go work out
do what will actually benefit you while
having fun it's it's not difficult it's
not crazy but people want the easy way
out people would love to be able to take
a pill and feel pleasure for two hours
straight and if such a thing existed
they would be taking it like crazy
but no one wants to do what's actually
beneficial for themselves and that's why
liberalism is slowly killing people
they're slowly killing human values
they're slowly killing us and they're
pushing us more and more into a dystopia
and Islam is the solution for all of
that and that's why you should become a
Muslim today
and Celine bro
let me ask you a message if somehow
let me ask you a message let me give you
a message let me ask you a question if
somehow you ended up on this video
um or someone can clip this and give it
to him but
I get it bro I get I've been there I get
it you wanna you know sort out your
Affairs and then come to Allah you want
to sort out your Affairs then get on
Dean you're not Dean right now because
you're doing XYZ you want to stop doing
XYZ and then you want to come back to
Allah I get it
if I can ask you a question without
sounding arrogant
but
it says who can you can you prove to me
that you got that time
just like Romney said can you do you
have a guarantee
is there something you know that Allah
doesn't know
is there something you know that we
don't know is there do you have
Assurance over over like that you're
gonna you know make it five years ten
years 15 years 20 years and then you can
come back to Allah what if you don't
what if in that process of you know
let's say God forbid bro something
happens to you
and then Allah asks you
my slave not only have I made the
message clear as day
but you're out here on a video saying
eventually I'm gonna come back like you
know this is the correct path why didn't
you
and you're gonna be like Ya Allah if
only you gave me another five years I
would have done it Allah if only gave me
another day I would have done it
I you didn't let me live long enough I
was gonna do it do you think I was gonna
fly
like just genuinely I'm just open
question bro think about it
you know I forgot we're reacting to
Salim honestly and I feel bad because I
feel like I went in to a video it was
good bro sometimes sometimes we ought to
go in and and Celine please bro if if
you want to get on a podcast with us
even if it's off camera bro we don't
care about the YouTube stuff just just
talk to us bro you know how to find this
you know
um it's easier to get a hold of us than
it is to get a hold of you because we're
not famous alhamdulillah actually it's a
good thing I'd rather not be famous but
um please get a hold of us get in touch
with us get your people to get in touch
with us we don't have people and and
just reach out to us please and let's
talk about it bro because I'm born
Muslim too romy's born Muslim too
no one's an angel
Rami was a freak now I'm just playing
around he's not a freak because Ram is
amazing bro ROM is amazing if anything I
was more into jahiliya than Rami and and
the reality is we've all been there but
sometimes something Clicks in your head
where you're like you know what this is
it
and I would rather this is just me
I would rather accept it now
make my life a little bit harder now but
I know I'm on the right path and I don't
have guilt
than to suffer the way that someone
likes like like I would if I was to do
what Celine was doing I'm not saying
Saleem suffering but if I was to do that
saying you know what bro I believe what
I'm doing is wrong I could die in any
moment but I'm gonna do it anyway
you know Paul from blogging theology you
guys should check out our episode with
him if you haven't but in that episode
um actually not in that episode the same
guy Paul from blogging theology I have
him on Instagram or YouTube he posted
this thing on YouTube it said a short
story
he said he was going to repent the next
morning but he died in his sleep
yeah I was like damn bro
it's powerful man it's powerful it's
sure and to the point
100 percent and um just as a final
message to the Saleem for myself
maybe you don't have to be perfect like
if I said to be Muslim you don't
listen being a Muslim means that you
submit your will to Allah
yes you're gonna slip you're gonna make
mistakes
he told us right that the best of of
Sinners or those who repent and that
Jannah is full of Sinners who repented
right we know
every single person
you know alive today every single Muslim
even the best I've send and made
mistakes some were huge some you might
see a small item regardless judgment is
only for Allah
once the truth comes
falsehood vanishes that's what Allah
says in the Quran
indeed falsehood is bound to vanish
so now you know the truth
just accept Islam come back to Islam you
won't be perfect
but find contentment in knowing that
you're not going to be perfect but Allah
will reward you for your efforts it
might take time for you to stop drinking
and whatever you're doing it might take
time but it's okay
but it's better that you do it while
being a Muslim than to continue down
this path of not being a Muslim and if
you're worried about whatever shame or
guilt you might feel while being a
Muslim and like drinking or whatever
just know that that shame and that guilt
is a good thing and it's there for a
reason and the moment you don't feel
guilty for doing that is the moment you
have a problem because the biggest
problem that you can have in life is not
knowing that you have a problem and that
guilt and shame tells you hey you're
doing something wrong you should
probably stop turn back to Allah and
people have this big misconception bro
thinking that time is infinite and we
have unlimited attempts at life
the thing with sinning bro is it
blackens your heart every single time
you send it puts a black dot in your
heart eventually over time
it blackens your heart to the point
where you feel no remorse and no guilt
yeah this is to all the people that
think oh eventually I'm just going to
come back eventually bro What If
eventually you realize you know what I
don't need this or something anymore
I'm good